JULIE WISKIRCHEN: OK.
Hello, everybody.
I am Julie Wiskirchen.
From the Authors at Google team
here in Los Angeles, and
today, we're excited to
welcome Bruce Feiler.
Bruce writes the This Life
column about contemporary
families for the Sunday "New
York Times," and he's the
author of five consecutive New
York Times best sellers
including "Walking the Bible,"
and "The Council of Dads." He
is the writer presenter of the
PBS series "Walking the
Bible," and the forthcoming
"Sacred Journeys with Bruce
Feiler."
He has written for numerous
publications, including "The
New Yorker," "The New York
Times Magazine," and
"Gourmet," where he won three
James Beard awards.
He's also a frequent contributor
to NPR, ABC, NBC,
CBS, CNN, and Fox News.
And today, Bruce is here to talk
about his new book, "The
Secrets of Happy Families." So
please join me in welcoming
Bruce Feiler.
BRUCE FEILER: Good afternoon,
and thank you all for coming.
I'm delighted to be here, though
my wife, upon hearing
that was going to give this
talk, insisted that I begin
with this disclaimer, which is
that I wrote about happy
families, not because I had one,
but because I wanted one.
As many of you know, I grew up
in Savannah, Georgia, and as
you just heard, spent many years
of my life-- almost two
decades-- traveling around the
world, entering different
worlds, and writing
about them.
I wrote a book about Japan,
about England, many years
traveling around the
Middle East.
And yes, it's true, I did spend
a year performing as a
clown in a traveling circus.
And I would go out and enter--
I would even say brazenly
enter--
these different worlds, and try
to become a part of them.
But I found a few years ago when
I became a parent that,
in the world of family, in the
world of my own house, I felt
completely lost.
And a few years ago, all of
this came to a head--
this incredible chaos, and the
sense that we were always on
the defense as parents.
My family gathers every summer
for a two week extended family
reunion on Tybee Island off
the coast of Savannah.
In fact, I am the father of soon
to be eight-year-old now
identical twin daughters.
One of them is named Eden, for
the garden of Eden, and one of
them is Tybee, named for this
island in Savannah, where I
grew up and where
we got married.
And we had just a number of
years ago-- we just gotten
through that long slog of sippy
cups and diaper caddies,
and we were ready to form
a family culture.
And I'd been thinking, we talk
so much in this culture about
racing the biological clock to
have our children, but yet,
there's this other biological
clock that we're also racing
that we don't really talk
about, and that is the
biological clock of before our
children grow up and don't
want anything to do with
us as parents again.
So there's this kind of window
that we have to develop a
family culture.
And to be honest, we
didn't really know
how to go about that.
How do you teach kids values
in a 24/7 world?
How do you make sure that they
have that bond with their
family that's very tight
before they go off
and enter the world?
So we were struggling with those
issues, my wife and I.
And we were the first
to arrive at this
extended family reunion.
My little sister came next.
She has older children.
Her kids were preteens at the
time, and they were facing
their challenges--
prying their kids' noses out
of their digital devices,
teaching their kids
about money, and
sex, and cyber stalking.
My older brother came next.
He doesn't have children.
And he was very focused
on my aging parents.
Was it time to put Dad in
a wheelchair full time?
Was it time to ask mom to
stop driving at night?
So all these issues were kind
of swirling in our family as
we got together, and sure
enough, on that first night,
everything became exploding
out onto the table.
We were sitting down to dinner,
and I noticed out of
the corner of my eye
that my nephew was
texting under the table.
And yes, I knew I shouldn't say
anything, but I couldn't
help myself.
And I asked him to
put it away.
Kaboom!
It was like a mushroom
cloud exploded.
My sister snapped at me not to
parent her children, my father
pointed out that it was my
daughters who were balancing
spoons on their noses, my mother
said, from her point of
view, none of the grandchildren
had
manners to speak of.
And at that point, my wife got
up and fled to the kitchen to
get ice cream, exactly as
her mother would have
done in this instance.
But they haven't finished their
vegetables, I said, at
which point, everybody got up
and fled to separate corners
of the house.
Later that night, my father
called me to his bedside, and
there was this palpable quiver
in his voice I couldn't
remember hearing before.
Our family's falling
apart, he said.
Oh, no it's not, I said,
without thinking.
We're stronger than ever.
But lying in bed that night,
I began to wonder.
Was he right?
What is the secret sauce
that holds families
together these days?
What are the ingredients that
make some families effective,
resilient, happy?
It turns out to be an
astonishingly good time to ask
that question.
The last few years have seen a
remarkable transformation--
an explosion of knowledge about
all the things that
families are challenged with.
Dinner time, discipline,
difficult conversations.
There are breakthrough ideas
about how to make teams and
groups run more effectively, not
just in families, but in
so many different worlds.
The problem is that parents are
in this straitjacket, that
the only ideas we are allowed
to implement must come from
what I call the family
improvement industry--
shrinks and self help gurus
and other family experts.
But as you know, in so many
different worlds, from Silicon
Valley to corporate America,
from championship sports
teams, even to the US military,
there's all this new
knowledge about how to make
groups run smoothly, be
effective, be resilient, bounce
back from difficulties
more quickly.
The problem is that most of
that knowledge remains
ghettoized in that world, cut
off from the families, from
the parents who need it most.
So I spent the last few years
traveling around, entering
these different worlds, and
trying to figure out what
parents in those worlds were
taking home and doing with
their families.
What is the research behind
these new ideas that they're
implementing?
And then I brought those
ideas back home to my
own wife and kids.
When I set out on this project,
I made two promises
to myself, and one promise
to my wife.
I met the vow I made to her, and
I didn't meet the two vows
I made to myself.
So the vow I made to her was
that she said, I'm willing to
try any new idea that you come
up with, but I don't want
anything based on theory.
I want to know that actual
families are doing these
actual ideas.
The two vows to myself were
more problematic.
The first vow I made was that I
wasn't going to talk to any
therapists, and I did
violate that.
I actually spoke to a Belgian
sex therapist.
It was the only one I talked to,
but I did break that vow.
The other vow that I made to
myself was that I wasn't going
to take what I learned and
cram it into some clever
little list of the two or three
or five or seven things
that you have to do to
have a happy family.
I don't know about you,
but I find those
lists incredibly stressful.
What happens if I disagree
with number two, or if I
forget number four?
Am I doomed to have
an unhappy family?
The truth is, I don't think
there is such a list.
In fact, one of the things
I've tried to do in The
Secrets of Happy Families is
specifically put 200 new ideas
out onto the table, because it
would be very clear that with
200, nobody could be expected
to do them all.
But if you take the three or
four or seven that apply to
your family, and that most
resonate with you, and you
bring them home, I'm almost
prepared to guarantee that
you'll have a happier
family in a week.
Having said that, it did turn
out that certain themes did
keep emerging with all the
families I was talking to, and
all of the experts I was
interviewing, and all the
research I was looking at.
And what I want to do here today
is lay out two of those
broad themes.
And before I do that, I just
want to set the table here by
saying, one of the things that
I clearly learned, and the
research clearly shows, is
that we have learned a
tremendous amount in the first
generation of positive
psychology.
And maybe the number one thing
that we have learned that
makes people happy
is relationships.
Happiness by almost every
measure is other people, and
the other people that matter
most to us are our family.
But what is staggering, maybe
even shocking, is that we
spend so little time
actually trying
to improve our families.
Think about it.
We have our jobs.
We work on those.
We have our hobbies.
We have our bodies.
We work on those.
We have our families, but
somehow, this idea is out
there that our families
just are.
We're going to somehow
organically just know how to
raise a family.
But the truth is, for many
of us, it's not working.
But the good news is, there is
lots of know how out there.
And if you do small things,
and take small steps, you
actually can make your family
happier, and in the process,
make everybody in the
family happier.
So what's the first of the two
big ideas I want to talk about
here today?
It is high functioning families
adapt all the time.
Now, I thought when I became
a parent, no problem.
I'm just gonna set a few rules,
and we're going to
follow them, and everything
is going to work.
Turns out it doesn't
work that way.
There's absolutely no way that
what you're designing for your
family in September is going to
be relevant to the problems
you're going to be
facing in April.
You need to be able to
change in real time.
One of my favorite lines of
parenting comes from my friend
Justin, who had four children
in six years.
And he said, with children,
everything is a phase, even
the good parts.
Our lives are moving.
Our kids are adapting
all the time.
Just when they stop teething,
they start having tantrums.
Just when they stop needing our
help taking a bath, they
need our help dealing
with online bullies.
We are constantly being
forced to change.
And the reality is, we're
always playing defense.
We're always reacting
to the situation.
We're not really playing
offense.
Ellen Galinsky of the Families
and Work Institute asked 1,000
children, if you could be
granted one wish about your
parents, what would it be?
The parents all guessed the
children would say, spending
more time with them.
They were wrong.
The children's number one wish
was that their parents be less
tired and less stressed.
The reality is, we're out
of control, and our
children are onto us.
It's no wonder that Salvador
Minuchin, the great family
theorist from Harvard, said that
the family's number one
challenge is to be adaptable.
So has anyone figured
out how to do that?
At 7:00 on a Sunday evening,
in Hidden Springs, Idaho,
population 2,535, the six
members of the Star family
were sitting down to the
highlight of their week, the
family meeting.
The Stars are a typical American
family, with their
share of typical American
family problems.
David is a software engineer.
His wife, Eleanor, takes
care of their six
children, ages 10 to 15.
One of those kids has
Asperger's syndrome.
One ADHD.
One tutors math on the
far side of town.
One practices lacrosse
on the near side.
We were living in complete
chaos, Eleanor said.
I was trying that whole love
them and everything will work
out philosophy, but
it wasn't working.
For the love of God, I finally
said, I can't take it anymore.
What the Stars did next,
though, was surprising.
Instead of turning to friends
or relatives, they turned to
David's workplace.
And they turned to a radical
idea that at the time, was
just moving from automotive
manufacturers in Japan to
start ups in Silicon Valley.
And that idea was agile
development.
So since I'm sitting here
at Google, let's just
see a show of hands.
How many people here have heard
of agile development?
Almost full attendant.
I have to say, I've been asking
that question in talks
around the country, and I
usually get two or three hands
in whatever size room it is.
So let's talk about agile, OK?
And why it applies to something
as apparently
radically different
as families.
So the core idea--
I don't have to tell you-- but
the core idea of agile is that
companies were following what
was called the waterfall
model, which is executives
were issuing orders that
harried programmers were
following down below.
And by the time it got to those
programmers and they
came back with a project, it was
over budget, out of date,
and irrelevant.
83% of projects failed.
So the core idea of agile, of
course, is that you divide
people into small teams,
and you do things in
small chunks of time.
So instead of saying go off and
design me a search engine
or a cell phone, and come back
in two years, you say, design
me an element, come back,
and let's adapt.
Let's adjust.
Let's succeed or fail
in real time.
Let's constantly be changing.
What David Star said was when
he first brought these ideas
into his family, including
especially, the idea of a
weekly meeting to review the
progress, he said it lowered
stress, increased communication,
and made
everybody much happier to be
part of the family team.
When my wife and I brought these
ideas into our family,
including these family meetings,
it was the most
significant change we made into
our lives since the birth
of our children five
years earlier.
And these meetings did
all this while
lasting under 20 minutes.
So let's break this down a
little bit, and talk about why
it is that families
can benefit from
this kind of an idea.
So one of the principles of
agile, of course, is public
accountability.
We're all part of a team.
Everybody needs to know what
everybody else is doing.
That's why they have these
information radiators--
these large boards where
everybody's chronicling
everybody else's tasks.
So in the Stars, they adapted
this by creating a morning
checklist with a list of
obligations that each of the
children was expected
to tick off.
So in the morning that I was
in Idaho, Eleanor came
downstairs about 6:30, made
herself a cup of coffee, and
sat down in a reclining chair,
and she sat there and casually
chatted with each of her
children as one after the
other came downstairs, checked
the list, made themselves
breakfast, checked the list
again, put the dishes in the
dishwasher, re-checked the list,
fed the pets or whatever
was their task for the day,
checked the list again,
gathered their belongings, and
headed to the bus stop.
It was the single most
amazing family
dynamic I had ever seen.
And when I strenuously objected,
this would never
work in my house, that our girls
needed too much nagging
and too much prodding and too
much parental yelling, Eleanor
said, that's what I thought.
I said to David, keep your
work out of my kitchen.
But I was wrong.
So when I turned to David, why
does this have an impact?
He said, you can't underestimate
the power of
doing this.
And he made a check mark.
He said, in the workplace,
adults love it, and with kids,
it's heaven.
The week we introduced a morning
checklist into our
house, it cut parental
screaming in half.
But the biggest change
came when we
instituted this family meeting.
So we now hold a weekly
family meeting.
We do it every Sunday night.
It takes 15 to 20 minutes, and
we ask three questions based
on the agile family model.
Number one, what worked well
in our family this week?
Number two, what didn't
work well?
And number three, what
will we agree to work
on in the week ahead?
Everybody throws out ideas, then
we vote on two that we're
going to focus on.
And instantly, the most amazing
thing started coming
out of our daughters' mouths.
What worked well this week?
Making our bed, or clearing
the table.
What didn't work well?
Our math sheets, or greeting
visitors at the door.
Now, those of you who are
parents here among us--
I don't know about you,
but our children are
like Bermuda triangles.
Words and ideas go in, but
they never come out.
Like, their inner lives are
a complete mystery to us.
And what this idea has brought
into our lives is we now have
access to what our children
are thinking and feeling.
And it got extremely interesting
when we said, what
will we agree to work on
in the week ahead?
Because here is the key plank
to the entire idea.
We let our children, with adult
supervision, pick their
own rewards and punishments.
In the workplace, it functions,
and with kids, it's
absolutely magical and
absolutely transformative to
the family dynamic.
So we say, OK, what are we going
to work on this week?
And give me the reward
and the punishment.
So one of my daughters will
say, OK, if we greet five
visitors at the door, we get
10 extra minutes of reading
before bed.
If we kick somebody, we lose
desserts for a month.
Now, by the way, anybody who's
not done this says the kids
will be incredibly lax
in their punishments.
Anybody who's done
it knows the kids
are incredibly strict.
Our daughters are like
little Stalins.
We're constantly having
to dial them back.
Now, mind you, there is a gap
between what they say in these
meetings and their behavior
the rest of the week.
It's not like all the
problems go away.
But the truth is, for us, it
doesn't really bother us,
because we feel like we are
laying these underground
cables that aren't going to
fully light up their worlds
for many years to come.
We started these meetings when
our daughters were five.
Three years later, we are
still doing them.
My wife counts them as among
her most treasured
moments as a mom.
So what have we learned?
The first thing we've
learned is that you
have to make change.
You have to adjust
in real time.
What is incredibly effective
about the system is we don't
have to fight every battle the
minute that it erupts.
So if we're trying to get the
broccoli down on Tuesday
night, or if you're having to
discuss a curfew on Thursday
night, you don't have to have
every battle in the moment, in
the absolute chaotic stress
of that situation.
You know at the end of every
week there is going to be this
moment where you're going to
have a time where everyone's
going to sit down calmly, at
the same level, and have a
conversation about how the
family is functioning.
So the first thing we've learned
is to be mindful about
how we function as a family, and
set aside a small amount
of time every week where
we talk about it.
The second idea that we've
learned, as I mentioned
before, is that you have to
empower your children.
I can push my kids around.
I can elbow them into doing
something that I want.
I can tell them the same thing
over and over again.
It's easier, and by
the way, we're
usually right as parents.
But as parents all discover,
it doesn't actually work.
And the latest brain research
is showing that children who
set their own schedules, make
their own work plans, evaluate
their own progress,
they're actually--
from FMRI studies, we know
this-- they are building up
their prefrontal cortex, and
getting the skills they are
going to need later in life.
The point is, by having children
take agency over
themselves, you are helping
build the set of skills that
they're going to need to
function later in life.
Let me just give an example
of how this works.
So this week in our family,
we're working on overreacting.
I'm sure none of you has that
problem, but we have that
problem in our house.
OK, so we all agree we're going
to work on overreacting.
So we say to the kids, OK,
give me some rewards and
punishments.
One of my daughters says, OK,
how about we get five minutes
of overreacting this week, and
if we have fewer than five
minutes, we get to have
a sleepover at
the end of the week.
And if we have more than 15
minutes of overreacting, then
we'll do one push up for
every minute over 15.
Well, first of all, I never
would have picked a sleepover,
and I certainly wouldn't have
picked push ups as the
punishment.
But now I know this is going
to motivate them.
I'm learning.
I'm hearing back from them.
But when my other daughter
hears this about the five
minutes of overreacting, she
said, is that one five minute
overreaction, or 10 30
second overreactions?
And as far as I'm concerned,
this exchange is already a
success, because it's that math
that she's doing in our
head that's exactly the math
that I want her to do.
Now, by the way, we did some
push ups that week.
But as I said, that's not really
the headline from this
experience.
The headline is the actual
thought process of working.
In fact, a couple days later,
I was going out to do
something, and they were
playing a card game.
And sure enough, some conflict
erupted over the card game,
and one of my daughters started
overreacting, and
started screaming.
And her sister goes,
overreacting, overreacting,
and starts counting.
One, two, three, four.
And within 10 seconds, it
stopped, and it was a
certified family miracle.
The point is, whenever
possible,
empower your children.
Bring them into the conversation
about what it
means to be part of
your family unit.
And the last thing we learned is
that parents don't have all
the answers.
If that is not enough of an idea
for you, let's go even
one step further.
In this meeting, we actually
allow our daughters to
criticize their parents.
We actually let them let off
steam that they have, in a
sense, giving them stature
in the family.
This is not that the kids
run the asylum.
This is an ecosystem designed
by the parents.
There's still homework, and
manners and bedtime and all
these things that we insist, but
we are bringing them into
the process.
And as we know, there is scores
of studies, years of
research, that shows the most
effective teams are not
designed by charismatic
leaders.
Nothing is top down anymore.
Business is not top down,
religion is not top down,
government is not top down.
We cannot send our children into
a world where everything
that they've learned at home has
been the parents have all
the authority.
We have to prepare them
for the world
they're going to enter.
And I have to say,
they love it.
Just the other week, we were
having a family meeting, and
we said, what didn't work well
in our family this week?
And my girl said, Dad
yelled a lot.
In fact, they said they were
playing a game on the iPad
where they could record songs,
and they have a recording of
Dad yelling, so they have
proof that Dad yelled.
My wife thought this was the
greatest thing ever, and she
was like, yeah, high
five, high five.
You nailed Dad!
You got Dad yelling!
And then they turned to her, and
they said, yeah Mom, and
we recorded you cursing.
We live in a world where
the best ideas can
come from any place.
That's the idea that works
in this office.
This is an idea that parents
can learn a lot from.
So the first big theme that I
learned is adapt all the time.
The second big theme
that I learned--
I want to talk a little bit
about it right now--
is talk a lot.
High functioning families keep
a conversation going.
And it's not just difficult
conversations.
In fact, there's a chapter
in "The Secrets of Happy
Families" about how to talk
about sex, how to talk about
money, how to talk about aging
parents, how to fight smarter.
A lot of new ideas.
But the specific thing I want
to talk here about is that
high functioning families talk
a lot about what it means to
be part of your family.
I spoke to Jim Collins, the
author of Good to Great, the
defining management
book of the last
decade, as you all know.
And Jim said to me that
well run human
organizations of any kind--
could be companies, could be
countries, is also families--
do two things in common.
They preserve the core, and
they stimulate progress.
The stimulating progress is what
we've just been talking
about-- coming up with a system
to manage the change so
it doesn't manage you.
But what about preserving
the core?
Jim said that families can learn
a lot from another idea
that organizations do, which is
define their core identity.
And he coached us through this
process of creating a family
mission statement, modeled on
the mission statement that
many companies and
organizations do.
Now, when I first heard this
idea, I thought it was cold
and corny, and had completely
no appeal.
But then someone asked me a
question that caught me up
short, and the question
was this--
can your children actually
identify what values are most
important to you?
And I thought, I'd like to think
that they could, but the
truth is, I haven't really
articulated it to them.
They'd have to guess
it or divine it.
So Jim coached us through this
process, as I said, of
creating a family mission
statement.
So we have a family equivalent
of a corporate retreat.
We had a pajama party.
We all piled into our bed.
I made popcorn, although
actually, I burned one batch.
I had to make a second batch.
And we had the most amazing
conversation.
First of all, I took a list of
80 values, which I have here
in the book for those of you
who want to do it, which I
took from management manuals,
from education books, from
happiness books.
And we went through what's
really important to us.
Honesty is the best policy.
I say that all the time, but
really, a core value?
Is that going to be one of the
things that's most central to
who we are?
So we said, what do we like
most about our family?
Kids, when you're leaving, what
do you miss most about
being with our family?
When you have friends over to
our house, what is it that you
most like them to see
about our family?
And we ended up with this
a list of 10 statements.
We like to travel.
We're travelers.
So one of them is, we're
travelers, not tourists.
One of them is a line that my
wife uses all the time--
we don't like dilemmas,
we like solutions.
One of them is, we help
others to fly.
A key finding of the happiness
research is, if you want to
improve yourself, you have
to articulate your
best possible self.
What this is, in effect,
is articulating our
best possible selves.
What is the family
we want to be?
And we've now hung it in a
prominent place in our home.
And we saw benefits
right away.
A few weeks later, we got
a call from the school.
One of my daughters had gotten
into a spat with a classmate.
And back to my idea that parents
don't have all the
answers, we didn't
know what to do.
We hadn't had this experience
before.
So we called my daughter into
my office, and my wife was
kind of grasping for straws,
to be honest.
And the flip chart that we
had-- and we made this.
It was still up on my wall.
And my wife said, anything
up there seem to apply?
And my daughter looked,
and she said, we
bring people together?
And boom, suddenly, we had a
way into the conversation.
So create a family mission
statement.
But talking about what it means
to be your family also
can go one step further, and it
can happen at other times
of the day.
And in order to talk about a few
of these ideas, I need to
address the pink elephant
in the room, and
that is family dinner.
All parents have been told that
having family dinner is
good for your children.
And the truth is, there's lots
of research to back this up,
and if you can have family
dinner with your
kids, that's fantastic.
But here's the problem.
It doesn't work In most
of our lives.
My wife doesn't even come home
from work until 6:30.
Americans rank 33 out of 35
countries in a UN study about
who eats family meals
together.
But dig deeper into the
research, and the news is
actually quite revealing and
fascinating for parents.
Nothing has been more studied
in the family space than
family dinner.
Tens of thousands have been
studied, and taped, and
logged, and every you know,
um, and like has been
chronicled.
And it turns out there's only
10 minutes of meaningful
conversation in any
family dinner.
The rest is taken up with take
your elbows off the table and
pass the ketchup.
And the research shows you can
take that 10 minutes and move
it to any time of the day, and
have the same benefit.
So if you can have family
dinner, great.
But if you can't, have
family breakfast.
Meet for a bedtime
snack at 8:30.
Even one meal on the weekends
has the same benefit.
Because here's the point.
The point is, what you're
talking about, the family
part, matters much more
than the dinner part.
But what should you actually
be talking about in those
exchanges, whenever
you have them?
Could be at night, could be on
a, walk could be in a carpool.
We collected about two dozen
different ideas for family
conversations, and we tested
them all in our house with
friends, and relatives, and
people of different
generations.
And I put 10 in my book
that worked the
best, from my research.
I call them the Hunger Games.
And I want to mention just three
of them here tonight--
things you can do in a family
conversation that will serve
everybody in the family.
Idea number one, word a day.
Kids in 1st to 12th grade
have to learn
3,000 new words a year.
You can help by teaching your
kids one new word a day.
When you talk to babies,
naturally, as you know, we
elevate our voices and we do
this thing called baby talk,
and the research shows that
actually helps children with
phonics and understanding how
to read and how to speak.
But the truth is, when they get
older, you want to stop
using baby talk, and talk
more like yourself.
So you want to teach them new
words, and one way we learned
about that my wife loved was
we bring a newspaper.
You guys know what that is?
It comes in paper, and
there are stories.
We bring newspapers and
magazines-- by the way,
catalogs are fantastic.
A J.Crew catalog has enough
color names that are new to be
word a day for two months.
So what happened was,
interesting story.
So my wife would bring these
to the table, and we would
begin this conversation about
new words that we didn't think
that they would know.
And by the way, I'm a big
advocate-- in fact, I wrote an
article in the York Times-- it
is OK to Google at dinner.
Even if you have a rule that
you put your devices away,
which is great for kids, it is
OK if you're actually Googling
to learn new knowledge.
And I'm well on the
record about this.
So it's OK to Google
at dinner.
AUDIENCE: Googling--
what's that?
BRUCE FEILER: Yeah.
I call your attention to
the logo behind me.
Googling is what you do when
you're on your surfboard, and
you want to know what the
jet stream is going to
be doing that day.
But here's what happened, OK?
So we were teaching our kids new
words a day, and it turned
out they know all these words
from school-- the slang and
these words that they use with
their students, and suddenly,
they wanted to teach
a new word to us.
So suddenly, by complete
happenstance, we had stumbled
into this great conversation
topic, where ideas
we're going both ways.
One new word a day.
Idea number two.
Autobiography night.
Beginning at age five, kids
learn to narrate a story about
their lives, but they have to
actually practice this skill.
And the research shows that
parents who ask more elaborate
questions, is the academic term
for it-- who what when,
where, how, and why--
will help their children
learn this skill.
Asian American researchers in
Boston looked at American moms
and Asian moms.
Sure enough, the American moms
asked more elaborate
questions, had their children
telling more stories about
their lives.
The Asian moms were talking more
about the schedule, and
the discipline, and the hard
work of the family.
These Asian American researchers
went back three
years later.
The American children had a
higher sense of self esteem
and identity, and the Asian
children knew more about the
schedule, and the work,
and the discipline--
what is valued in
these cultures.
Don't think this makes
a difference?
Researchers have shown that
children who tell a simple
story about themselves--
about a past success
in their lives--
if they do this the night
before, or the morning of a
big test in school, or an
athletic competition, their
performance will rise.
So if they remind themselves
that they got through a
difficult task in the past, it
will give them confidence to
get through the difficult task
in front of them on that day.
And the last idea I want to
talk about is my single
favorite idea from "The Secrets
of Happy Families,"
and the idea is this--
talk about your family
history.
Researchers at Emory
gave children a
simple do you know test.
Do you know where your
grandparents were born?
Do you know where your parents
went to high school?
Do you know an aunt or an uncle
who had an illness or
something difficult that
they overcame?
The children who scored highest
on this test, which
means who knew more about their
family history, had a
higher sense of self confidence,
and a greater
belief that they could control
their own lives.
It was the single biggest
predictor of a child's
emotional health
and happiness.
As the lead researcher explained
to me, these
children understand that they're
part of something
larger than themselves--
an inter-generational
self, he called it.
There are three types of
family narratives.
There's an ascending
family narrative.
We had nothing, we worked
hard, we have it all.
There's a descending
family narrative.
We have a lot, there was a
storm, a recession, a war, we
lost everything.
Now we have less.
There's an oscillating
family narrative.
We worked hard.
We had some success.
Your father opened a business.
Your mother was on the board.
But then your uncle
lost his job.
Well, we all rallied as a
family, and we got through it.
Then you had an aunt
who had cancer.
Children who understand they're
part of an oscillating
family narrative have a greater
believe that they can
get through their own
difficult times.
And that really is the headline
from this study, and
in a way, from this whole
idea of talking
about your family history.
You want to spend time talking
about your family's positive
moments, but even more
important, talk about the
family's negative moments, and
how you overcame and rallied
through them, so when children
hit their own hurdles, they'll
believe that that's just part of
life, and they can get over
their hurdles.
As I said, when I set out on
this project, I was determined
not to cram everything into a
list of two or three or five
secrets that all happy families
have in common.
And in fact, I don't think
such a list exists.
What works for your family is
different from your family, is
different from my family.
But the number one thing I've
learned is how important our
family is to our overall
identity.
I grew up in a time, as many
of you here, where we were
told that the individual
is the most
important thing in society.
But everything that we've
learned, and particularly what
has come out of the world of the
internet, has told us that
actually, naturally, we are
inclined to be in groups, to
be in networks, to
be on teams.
No team, no group, no network is
more important to you than
your family, and there are
things you can do to improve
that family.
And what I've found, as I said,
is that there are three
large things that
high functioning
families have in common.
Number one, they adapt
all the time.
As I've been saying over and
over again, you need to be
able to change what you're
doing depending on the
circumstance.
There's an idea that I don't
have to tell you that those in
the internet world know, which
is, if you're doing the same
thing on the Internet that you
were doing six months ago,
you're doing the wrong thing.
Families can learn
a lot from that.
The second idea is talk a lot.
Not just difficult
conversations, but talk about
what it means to be part
of your group.
And the last big point, which
I haven't really touched on
today, but I do want to
throw it out here,
is go out and play.
It sounds incredibly simple,
and yet it's
the one that we forget.
The research is very clear.
All families have conflict.
If you can limit and control
that conflict, you can spend
more time building the
positive memories.
Parents should spend less time
worrying about what they do
wrong, and more time focusing
on what they do right.
So whatever it is you enjoy
doing as a family--
it could be surfing, it could
be cooking, it could be
hiking, it could be doing
jigsaw puzzles--
find some family members, find
some time, make memories.
I was a teenager when I first
read "Anna Karenina," and I
encountered what may be the
most famous line in world
literature.
All happy families are alike.
Each unhappy family is unhappy
in its own way.
And when I first read it, I
thought it was idiotic.
Of course all happy families
are not alike.
There's big ones, there's small
ones, there's loud ones,
there's quiet ones.
But working on this project,
I have changed my mind.
Today, for the first time, we
have comprehensive knowledge
about what it is that makes
families function.
We know there are critical
skills that families can have
to be able to work through
problems, bounce back from
setbacks, make positive
experiences, and run their
family life less chaotically,
more successfully.
Is it possible, all these
years later, to
say Tolstoy was right?
The answer, I believe, is yes.
When Leo Tolstoy was five years
old, his brother Nikolai
came to him and said he had
discovered the secret to
universal happiness, and he had
engraved it on a little
green stick which he
had buried in the
family's ravine in Russia.
And if the stick was
ever found, all
humankind would be happy.
You can actually see the note
that Tolstoy wrote, because he
became obsessed with this stick,
but he never found it.
And late in his life, he wrote
a note, which you can type
into Google and find, which
says, he wants to be buried in
that ravine.
He still lies there today,
covered in a
layer of green grass.
And that story, to me, captures
maybe the final
lesson that I learned.
Happiness is not something
we find.
It's something we make.
Almost anybody who's looked at
great organizations has come
to pretty much the
same conclusion.
Greatness is not a matter
of circumstance,
it's a matter of choice.
You don't need a grand plan.
You don't need a big scheme.
You need to take small steps,
accumulate small wins, keep
reaching for that green stick.
And that, in the end, may be
the greatest lesson of all.
What's the secret to
a happy family?
Try.
Thank you very much.
So we have about 15
minutes left.
I tried to leave ample time
for you to ask questions.
I know some of you may have to
scoot back to work, but who
would like to get us started?
AUDIENCE: I'll volunteer.
BRUCE FEILER: Great.
AUDIENCE: What you say
makes a lot of
sense, practically speaking.
You have twins.
At some point, they reach an
age where they can start
participating in the process.
Obviously, six months
old is too early.
Eight years old is too late.
Wherever works for them.
What do you do in families
where you have, say, a
five-year-old and
a two year old?
BRUCE FEILER: Well,
two questions.
Let me answer that question.
There's two sides to this
question, which is, when is
old enough, and when
is too old?
Because both questions will
inevitably come up.
The Stars, who had been doing
a lot of these agile ideas
first, and a lot of families I
look at, start, if you have
two or three or sometimes four
children, five children,
whatever it may be--
if there is a range, maybe
sometimes the older children
may be ready for it, but the
younger children may not.
In the morning checklist, I
know families that have
younger children often will
start with an ideogram,
because the children
can't read.
And I've been talking to
a lot of families--
this family meeting
idea is really--
a lot of people been writing
me since the book has been
out, and I will pause to mention
that it's number five
on "The New York Times"
bestseller list this week, so
people have been reading it
and reaching out to me.
And they've been saying, well,
the meeting hasn't been
working, or it has
been working.
I think part of the messaging
here is, this
is part of our family.
We're going to have these
meetings, and they may not
always work.
It took us a long time to
get the hang of them.
And what we did wrong at the
beginning was, we were talking
about what about what went well
in your life, or what did
not go well in your life?
And that's irrelevant
to the meeting.
We actually played games
like this at dinner--
bad and good.
Everyone goes around and says
what they did bad today, and
everyone goes around and says
what they did good.
Some people call this roses and
thorns, some people call
it highs and lows.
The Obamas call it
highs and lows.
They play it in the
White House.
But that's irrelevant.
We're talking about how
we work as a family.
So I think you can start it
whenever the oldest child is
ready to do it, and if the other
one's running around,
they're still going to learn
that this is important.
And my guess is, as we know,
with kids of different ages,
the younger children tend
to be tugged along.
The younger children usually--
not always, but usually-- walk
faster, speak faster, because
they're trying to catch
up with the behavior
of the older children.
Let's now talk about the other
side which also comes up,
which is what about teenagers?
We know from the research, and
we know from life experience,
that kids between 12 and 16
spend half as much time with
their parents, and twice as much
time with their peers.
So we know that they
already have one
foot out of the family.
And David Star, for example,
very clearly said to me he
feels that a lot of this agile
methodology actually works
better with older children,
because at that point, they're
taking more responsibility.
But the question is, how do
you get them to the table?
With younger kids, one
of the things we do--
we play a quick game.
We play a game called Ma at the
beginning of our meeting,
where we go, Ma, Ma, Ma, and
everyone takes a turn, and
then we stop.
Welcome to the family meeting.
Ma.
We do that at the beginning
and the end, to
kind of have a marker.
And we also-- and by the way,
this works with kids in their
single digits--
we put allowance at the end of
the family meeting, because
that incentivizes the kids
to stick around.
But with older kids, here's
what's going to happen.
They're going to say, I don't
want a family meeting.
I'm too old.
I'm above it all.
But they're going to come to you
at one point and say, can
I stay out past my curfew
at Johnny's house?
Or, can I go to the movie with
Susie, which I didn't tell you
about in advance?
And the parent at that point
says, sorry, I'm
walking out the door.
Or I'm flossing my teeth right
now, and we're not going to
talk about this.
If you want to do this,
you've got to come
to the family meeting.
Because we're a system, and
once you make a change, it
affects everybody.
And that's the large
point here.
I mentioned the flossing
teeth, because
it's been on my mind.
Because recently, my wife came
into my office at 11:00 at
night, and I'm answering email,
and she's flossing her
teeth, right?
Things are flying everywhere.
And she says, so, did
you deposit the
money in the bank account?
Because we have to pay down
the mortgage this month.
And my response was,
wait a minute.
There's a whole chapter
in my book about
talking about money.
And I said, remember
what we've learned?
We're not going to have these
conversations at 11:00 at
night when you're flossing
your teeth and
I'm doing my email.
We're going to have a regular
time where we're going to sit
down and talk about money.
And that's the message
with older kids.
Sorry, we're not to change
the system in midstream.
We're going to come up with a
special time where we're going
to sit and talk about how
we work as a family.
Thank you.
Who would like to go next?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm an only child, and I have
one child, and I don't plan on
having more.
So one thing that I want to
avoid in raising my child is I
was very much a focus to my
parents, and it kind of cause
a little bit of resentment,
because I felt like I could
never let them down, and I
didn't have anybody to
commiserate with.
So in your research, did you
see any differences in
families with only children
versus multiple children?
BRUCE FEILER: Well, the short
answer is, this wasn't a big
topic of mine.
But the longer answer is no.
That what I chose to do was not
look at the makeup of the
family, but actually look
at the problems
that families face.
So rather than breaking families
into single families,
adoptive families, blended
families, I broke the family
down into things
that we all do.
We love, we play, we fight, we
have difficult conversations,
we teach our kids about
sex and money.
And each of my chapters is
about a different thing.
Because basically, three big
changes have gone on in the
family in the last generation.
Change number one is that
there's been a change in what
it means to be a family.
We have so many different
kinds of families.
I just mentioned adopted,
blended, gay, straight, we
have nuclear families that live
in separate houses, we
have divorced families that
nest in the same house.
So the definition of the family
has changed, but the
things that we struggle
with have not.
But there are also two other
changes I want to mention.
One is that women have come
flooding into the workplace,
which is discussed, actually,
quite a lot, as we all know.
And as we know, going
on right now.
But there's this other change
that's actually less
discussed, which is that dads
have come flooding into the
parenting space, and fathers
are much more involved now
than they ever were.
But I think in particular what
that has done is erase the
church state divide
that once existed
between work and family.
And technology--
I'm here at a technology firm--
makes a big difference.
We now know that busy parents
can check in with their
children during the day at
sports practice, or their
homework in the afternoon.
We also know that technology
allows workers to check in
with their colleagues
in what was once
family time in the evening.
So I think one of the reasons
that a lot of the ideas I've
been talking about here are
so alive and well in the
parenting world today is because
this new generation of
parents has less time, wants
smarter proven ideas that
work, and they're less
interested in this divide--
the old days when my dad would
come home at 5:30, and he and
my mom would sit down and have a
drink and have their private
time, and then we would have
family dinner at 6:00.
There are still families that
do that, but that is a very
profound minority now.
Most people are living with
technology coming at them all
times of the day, and they have
to find this family time.
And so my hunch is that the
challenge you faced as an only
child, where there was so
much intensity between
you and your parents--
if that's the biggest problem
you have with your children,
that's a blessing, because most
parents have the opposite
problem, which is not enough
intensity, and not enough time
to spend with their children.
So my guess is that that's not
going to be as much of a
problem for your child as you
may have felt growing up.
AUDIENCE: I have 11 and 13 year
old boys, and I have a
father who's rather sick in Palm
Springs two hours away.
He's in his 70s.
Do you talk at all in your book
about how to manage that
balance of how to parse
out the little time I
have with my family?
BRUCE FEILER: In some ways, this
whole book is an answer
to that question, because
I, too, have
aging and ailing parents.
I live in Brooklyn.
My parents live in Georgia.
My father has Parkinson's, and
can't travel as much, so
getting to Georgia
is a conflict.
We do it two or three times a
year, but it's still hard.
My in-laws live in Boston, and
my mother in law just spent
the last year fighting cancer.
So we definitely felt squeezed
between aging parents and
rising children.
And it is a large theme of this
book of how to work on
that balance.
One of my favorite chapters, and
I'm glad I get to mention
this, because there's a Google
reference in it, is called
Talk About the Marshmallow.
And it's about how to have
difficult conversation among
adult siblings dealing with
challenges, a lot of them
having to do with managing
parents.
And there is a tremendous amount
of knowledge out there.
There's a whole chapter
in my book about
how to fight smarter.
I went and took a three day
course from the folks at the
Harvard Negotiation Project
on how to make peace in my
family, both between warring
siblings, and between my wife
and I, who were having a fight
at 7:42 every night, and we
were talking about who's
dropping off the dry cleaning,
who's booking the tickets
for Thanksgiving, who's
picking up the milk.
We kept getting into a fight,
and I wanted to know how to
solve that.
And we learned a
bunch of ideas.
And one of the ideas I learned
is that the highest stress
time in families is between
6:00 and 8:00.
So we learned that 7:42 is the
worst time of day to have this
conversation, and we no
longer do it there.
And there's a bunch of ideas
about where to sit, how to
sit, how to make that
conversation work better.
But I want to talk about
particularly this challenge of
how to-- do you have siblings?
AUDIENCE: A brother, but he's
not allowed to help.
BRUCE FEILER: Well, he's
OK, so fine.
And my guess is, is
he farther away?
AUDIENCE: He's a long-haul
trucker, so he's--
BRUCE FEILER: Oh,
he's a long--
OK.
So this is the challenge
that we find.
My brother's in Atlanta.
He's close to my parents.
We're farther away.
How do you get people involved
if they are far away?
And one of the first things I've
learned is, opposite of
what you think is-- too few
cooks spoil the broth.
So if you're making a difficult
decision, do you
have to put your parents
in a nursing home?
Is it time to ask a relative
to stop driving?
Do you need to confront an
adult sibling who may be
having a substance
abuse problem?
The first lesson is, too few
cooks spoil the broth.
So you want as many people in
the conversation, even if they
say, I'm a long haul trucker.
I don't have time to join
this conversation.
Actually, your advice
is very valuable.
We were deciding whether
my mom should buy
long term care insurance.
I said, we want to a family
meeting on the phone to
discuss it.
My sister said, I don't know
anything about insurance.
My brother said, I'm too
busy with other things.
I said, we want everybody
there, even if you're
impatient, even if you know
nothing, because the research
clearly shows groups make
better decisions than
individuals.
Next, if you are having one of
these difficult conversations,
vote first and speak later.
Again, the research shows,
get everyone's
opinion on the table.
The group will make
a better decision.
If not, the person who speaks
loudest and first will
influence everybody else, even
if they don't know what
they're talking about.
We're going to talk about is it
time to put granddad in a
nursing home?
Everybody is going to say
whether they should or not at
the beginning, then you're
going to talk about it.
Then the conversation
will go better.
And here's my favorite tip,
which may not apply if you
just have a brother, but
I think it will.
I was actually talking to an
executive at Google at dinner,
and I said, what's going
on in your work?
And he actually worked
up in Mountain View.
And I said, what's going on in
your office that can help me?
And he said, in our office in
Google-- and for all I know,
it's happening down here-- we
try to have at least two women
in every meeting.
And I said, well, why is that?
And he pointed me to this study
from Carnegie Mellon--
it's actually in my book--
that they looked at do groups
make better decisions than
individuals?
Answer yes.
What is one of the factors?
If there's only one woman in
the group, the woman will
defer to the man.
If there's more than one woman
in the group, the group will
reach consensus more quickly
and be more collaborative.
This has been shown in
workplaces, it's been shown on
corporate boards, it's been
shown on three judge panels at
the appellate level.
If you have more than one woman
in the group, the group
will make a better decision.
So if you are making a difficult
decision about your
parents, then if you have
siblings, get them in.
If you have aunts and uncles,
even if you have a friend--
get as many people in
the conversation.
The group will make
a better decision.
And then the last thing--
I want to reiterate
two points.
Point number one is, you want
to make sure that you're
having positive experiences
that are
outweighing the negative.
You want to bring your children
in contact with their
grandparents.
Have them do a task together.
If you want to reduce tension
among warring siblings or
among people of different
generations, give them a task
to do together.
It will remind them they
can cooperate.
Do that before a dinner or a
long car ride, and the group
will get along better.
So you want to enlist your
children into contact with
their grandparents to make
sure there are positive
memories that will help you
during all the slog where
you're doing all the back
and forth driving.
And then the last thing I would
say is, you want to be
open about the difficulty
with your kids.
You don't want to pretend that
you're a super mom who has all
the answers and can
do it by yourself.
One of the games that I
recommend in one of these
conversations--
could be a dinner
or a car ride--
is a game called Pain Points,
where everybody, parents and
children alike, goes around
and says what they're
struggling with.
And if you tell your children,
I'm struggling, because I
would like to go to your soccer
game, but grandma has
an important eye doctor's
appointment, and I don't know
what to do.
And if you bring your children
into that process of trying to
solve the tensions in your
family, you'll relieve the
stress on yourself, you'll
give them the skills, and
suddenly what becomes a
difficult experience becomes a
bonding experience.
And time and again, that is
what I've learned in this
process, which is,
it's difficult.
Our lives are chaotic.
They're out of control.
But you can, to use the phrase
of the day, you can lean into
those moments.
You can enlist people to help.
You can talk about this.
We're in a hard moment
right now.
We need everybody to rally.
I spend an hour last night
with a lawyer friend in
Beverly Hills last night who had
an 18-year-old child who
had herpes encephalitis.
And it was so severe, and she
spent so much time in the ICU,
that they actually had to take
off her skull and put it in
her body to let the brain
swelling relax.
She's one of the one in
a million who had a
recovery from this.
And when I was saying to this
dad, what did you learn from
this experience?
He said, my 15-year-old,
in the lead up to this
experience, was yelling at his
older sister, I hope you die.
That's how much there
was tension.
And he said, when we got into
this situation, my wife's way
of responding to it
was to sleep every
night in the hospital.
My way was to go to the hospital
and bring my work,
and bury myself in my work as
we waited for this recovery.
But my 15-year-old, he's
a young person.
He got on the internet.
He started searching.
He's the one who wanted
all this information.
And having that rupture in the
normal family life allowed
everyone to realize
how dependent
they are on one another.
In a lot of ways, what I'm
talking about here is, can you
make that rupture?
Can you break that routine, even
without going through a
horrible situation like that?
And the answer, I
believe, is yes.
You can take small steps.
You can accumulate small wins.
You can make the
family happier.
You can make everybody in
the family happier.
Thank you very much.